i wake up every morning in a bed that's
too small
driving my daughter to a school that's
too expensive and then i go to work to a
job for which i get paid too little
but on pretzel day well i like pretzel
day
cause they're acting all tough and
everything but what they were rapping
about was cupcakes the chronicles of
narnia
uh who invented cupcakes right i wanna
kill hey hey hey
phyllis what are you doing i'm just
saying hi to bob
no i think you're cutting in line well
settle down scott no i'm not going to
settle down
no way uh-uh get in the back please
[Music]
thank you
that's right what a pair of mary's this
is pretzel day
and this next award is going out to our
own little pam beasley i think we all
know what award pam is gonna be getting
this year
it is the whitest sneakers award
because she always has the whitest
tennis shoes on
get on down oh here we go
okay first off my kids because i
couldn't have done it without them
thank you let's give michael a round of
applause
for emceeing tonight because this is a
lot harder than it looks
and also because of dwight too um
so finally i want to thank god
because god gave me this dundee
and i feel god in this chili's tonight
oh
what's this what is this i don't know
it's on your desk
but who put it here and for what purpose
is there when i sat down
happy valentine's day
it's me i'm the bobble head
yes ah
creed i noticed you don't have a
resolution on the board what's yours
i want to do a cartwheel but real casual
like
not make a big deal out of it but i know
everybody saw it this one stunning
gorgeous cartwheel how's it going i'm
having a little trouble motivating
look at where you're going to be doing
the cartwheel so look where you're going
to be placing your hands so pick a spot
you ready to do this yes sir you know
what i'm gonna stay here as long as it
takes
i really appreciate it i'm gonna spot
you i'll spot you you don't
go i
get it you did the perfect cartwheel
okay good the rush that's all i had to
do all year
congratulations all right well
all right see you tomorrow
you have seven unheard messages
hey jim it's pam i keep looking up to
say something to you and then michael's
there and it's horrible
anyway i'm bored come back
hey guess what i moved my computer so i
can't see michael's head
it's working i think i can have a career
as a very specific type of decorator
sudoku level moderate time 18 minutes
suck on that helper i'll transfer you
dunder mifflin this is pam hold please
dunder mifflin this is okay sorry
michael was standing at my desk and i
needed to be busy or who knows what
would have happened so thank you
hey what's that word we made up for when
you have a thing stuck in your shoe
anyway i have a thing stuck in my shoe
hey i have a chance to sneak out of here
early and i'm not messing this up so
i'll see you tomorrow
calling from my cell phone i don't know
if you guys figured out who did that to
michael's carpet yet but i have a theory
that involves an interdepartmental
conspiracy
everybody in the office we need to talk
and the town representative says
what do you call yourselves and the man
says the aristocrats
oh
ah i mean truly repulsive
acts that is a very very funny story
hey i want to say something
i've been trying to be more honest
lately and i just need to say a few
things
i did the coal walk just i did it
michael you couldn't even do that maybe
i should be your boss
what are we still doing here it's over
let's go home get the car
this is such a stupid idea this was
so stupid i am such a stupid idiot
i let everybody down everybody hates me
i lost everybody's jobs
nobody likes me anymore oh my god what
stanford is closed michael where did i
close
stanford is closed separately we did it
we did it we did it
right there right oh
i haven't heard anything but i'd bet jim
got the job
i mean why wouldn't he he's totally
qualified and smart
everyone loves him
and if he never comes back again
that's okay we're friends
and i'm sure we'll stay friends we just
we never got the timing right
you know i shot him down and then he did
the same to me
and but you know what
it's okay i'm totally fine
everything is gonna be totally fine
sorry
um are you free for dinner tonight
yes all right then it's a date
i'm sorry what was the question
[Music]
hey you want to sing with me
[Music]
i belong to west virginia
mama take me home
country room pick it in there
you have to stop
things are a little slow here and
there's only so much cold calling you
can do in a day
turns out there's no limit to the number
of cheese puffs you can throw at
someone's face
we're getting pretty good at it
[Music]
yes
attention everyone just a quick
announcement a little reconfiguration to
the staff
dwight schrute david can i just do one
thing while you're making this
announcement and then i'll
never ever do it again i don't think so
but it's just one thing
just let me do it come let me do this
come on what i was about to say is
dwight's
true can what uh
i i'm sorry i gotta this will be a
second sorry send it to voicemail
yeah ah
[Applause]
come on
and we'll get him a new set of drums oh
my god
oh my god
dwight schrute is
manager
you